us now with more on the mueller team
releasing flynn's interview document
is the author of the russia hoax fox
news legal analyst greg jarrett and fox
news contributor sarah carter
all right guys i'm excited to be doing
this here we've got
just released the new 302 we didn't even
know if there was a 302 because on
wednesday when judge sullivan ordered
that it be
turned in on friday we didn't get it on
friday but we get it today
it's heavily redacted and a 302 for the
viewers just so you know
is basically the interview of an
individual that is
that has turned into a report a 302.
it is supposed to be done uh uh
contemporaneously with the report
now what we have here is we now have a
version
of uh the january 24th uh
interview of michael flynn uh signed
february
one version in may and then we've got
one version in august
greg which one do you believe well i
think you have to look at the very first
one
uh usually the first is the most
authentic and honest
and it clearly states that these fbi
agents who interviewed michael flynn
determined that he was
telling the truth that he wasn't lying
but you know
these prosecutors mueller's prosecutors
tried to pull a fast one on this federal
judge emmett sullivan he was having none
of it
last friday they were supposed to hand
over these documents they
hid deliberately hid the 302 from the
judge he noticed it
and he issued a minute order today
saying
turn over that document so
that puts that's a red flag for the
judge it puts him on alert
during tomorrow's hearing he may say why
did you hide that document from me
well not only did they hide it but they
defied his order and didn't turn it in
on
friday if you and i did that we'd be in
control well
definitely that someone would be in
contempt and i'll go to you sarah
you know when mueller withholds a 302
which is the essence
of the the the statement that flynn made
which is the basis
of his his lying or as the feds see it
but as they see it to be honest with you
they said he really wasn't lying
so what we have here is a judge who
tomorrow
has a decision to make he can vacate the
plea
or he can allow the sentence to go
through which the
prosecution is recommending no time
well i think judge sullivan is not just
going to sit back and allow
mueller and the special counsel to walk
all over him i think he's definitely
going to make a statement
i also want to say um judge jeanine that
they didn't turn
in the raw notes that is the raw notes
from
the fbi agent joe pienka who was the
other agent who interviewed flynn
and that's extremely important because a
lot of times and i was talking to sydney
powell about this
a lot of times the raw material those
raw notes
are drastically different from the 302s
so the judge is going to want to compare
the raw notes of the fbi agents with
these 302s and remember
302 should be done within five days why
were these 302s
well there's three of them why were they
done consecutively and so far apart
and and i i'll give you an example of
how it's supposed to be done
hillary clinton was interviewed on july
2nd of 2016.
her 302 was done that day now we have
three
302s that they tried to hide from the
judge
that they redacted heavily and we don't
know which one is the accurate one and
there's something that stinks in river
city
and this judge knows it and he has deep
experience
with prosecutors who lie
deceive hide exculpatory evidence and
phony up false evidence it happened in
the
ted stevens case right this judge was
presiding
so you know look these are prosecutors
who don't care about justice and the
truth mueller's team
only cares about getting trump and
winning their cases
but this judge cares about justice
and he may turn to the prosecutors
tomorrow and say wait a minute
look at this 302 why did you charge a
guy with lying
when you don't think he was lying not
only that the judge has the authority to
vacate the plea that he has the
authority to dismiss in the interest of
justice
but what's interesting is that flynn did
not
make any of these motions the judge will
have to do it sue esponte
on his own will he and and notice the
judge
said don't tur he said don't turn this
over the defense turn it over to me
right i want to see these documents and
the judge may actually turn
to michael flynn and said what happened
here
uh if you didn't lie and the only two
witnesses said you didn't lie
were you coerced and forced did
mueller and his team threaten your son
did he cause you to essentially go
bankrupt and broke
is that why you pled but in addition to
that
in addition to that what he can say is
he can say
you know you intentionally dissuaded him
from bringing an attorney and although
this is not an a custodial interrogation
which would require miranda rights there
is a nuance here
and the nuance is when they say you
don't need a lawyer
and when they try to talk you out of it
sarah aren't they
in as bad a place as if they didn't
mirandize at all
absolutely they are and if you look at
the 302 itself
the lie is right up at the top of this
302
because they said they notified him of
the nature of this
interview and that is inaccurate they
never notified him of the nature of this
interview
because they asked him not to bring an
attorney and they were looking at him
for possible criminal purposes they were
trying in a sense
to entrap him because they already knew
what the conversation was
that he had with ambassador kislyak and
they were going to him so
i think the judge is going to be looking
at all of this and remember one thing
judge jeanine
that there's another fbi agent here
everybody
uh has talked about peter strzok
everybody has seen what
michael flynn has had to say but nobody
has spoken to the other fbi agent right
okay and rod rosenstein has refused to
make him available
not withstanding congressional demands
what are they hiding oh you
they're hiding everything that's the one
and they're delaying and you know
i must say that sarah when you talk
about the the beginning of the 302 it
says
after being advised of the identities of
the interviewing agents
and the nature of the interview flynn
provided the following information so
you're saying
they said to him we're looking at you to
interrogate you
uh regarding your statements and you're
saying that that didn't happen you have
information that that was not a fact
is that correct that's correct that's
correct you want to tell us from where
well the sources that i have spoken to
and i've written about this
even over six months ago uh judging
when he met with those agents at the
white house
he believed that he was having a
conversation and providing information
that was necessary information that they
would need which is the reason why
andrew mccabe said look you don't even
need to have an attorney there anyways
what would happen is i'd have to notify
the doj this is just a conversation
there was no way at that point in time
according to the sources that i've
spoken with
that uh lieutenant general michael flynn
thought
that he was being interrogated in fact
throughout half of that interview he
thought that they were just having a
normal conversation
got on the phone and lied to flynn
about the reason for the interview then
he pushed him not to have
oh you don't need to have a lawyer we
don't need to involve the lawyers in
this
and they conspired comey mccabe and
strzok and
pienka apparently conspired not to tell
flynn they had a transcript
of his very legal conversation with the
russian ambassador
but he already would know that wouldn't
he greg he would know that he's speaking
to the ambassador
did he know that sarah absolutely he
would have
he was the head of the defense
intelligence agency previously and then
he's a national security adviser
and so i think he was very well aware
that phone conversations were actually
being recorded
you know of foreign adversaries i don't
think what uh
or or even foreign state actors but i
don't think he would have thought
at any point in time that he was
actually being looked at as a suspect
because according to sources he never
believed he did anything wrong he never
believed he lied
he never did anything in addition to
that that 302 says he was colloquial and
friendly
that's right there is go ahead i mean it
was such a setup they lied to him over
it
they had a plan let's hurt trump uh you
heard comey bragging about it let's take
advantage
of the fact it's only three and a half
days in their administration they don't
have their lawyers
and all their ducks in a row i mean that
is unconscionable
but typically what the judge does
tomorrow